he is the unlikely star of an election
controversy that somehow
is still rumbling on brad raffensberger
the republican
who runs elections in georgia is
avoiding the question
do you think the president broke the law
in that phone call
get with our comments department and
we'll set up an interview what the
president asked of him on saturday is
now being investigated as a possible
crime
it was a look inside the mind of a man
who just won't let it go
all i want to do is this i just want to
find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state he didn't get
what he wanted but
did it break electoral law what we're
really seeing here in georgia
is that we're gonna have fair and honest
elections
truth matters facts matter it's as
simple as that
i need to follow the constitution we
will follow the constitution
but if the presidential election is
history now there's a vote in georgia
this week with real consequences
if democrats like rafael warnock win the
party will take control of the u.s
senate hugely significant to the
presidency of joe biden
and republicans here are worried that
every time donald trump talks about the
election being rigged
it raises doubts in the minds of
republican voters
and if they don't turn out it could be
very costly
i think many of them aren't are turned
off because they don't
they can't respect the office they can't
respect they
they think that the system is rigged but
they don't know who's rigging it he's
creating so much confusion for them
that some of them are just throwing up
their hands and staying home and not
voting at all
also in georgia the man who this week
will be asked to certify that election
defeat
remaining loyal you know i know we all
we all got our doubts about the last
election
and i want to assure you i share the
concerns of millions of americans about
voting irregularities and i promise you
come this wednesday
we'll have our day in congress we'll
hear the objections
we'll hear the evidence whatever his
boss's protests
there are barely two weeks left now
before donald trump leaves the white
house
for the final time